Hunter Hunter is back no this is not
clickbait after three long end with
frankly contentless years we have
finally receiving more of those glorious
chapters right so look how do we know
this well recently on Twitter a certain
account popped up with a certain name
that certain name being yoshihiro
tagashi the author of font Hunter and it
came equipped with tagashi's author
Avatar which is this here delightful dog
thing and at the time of recording this
account has only made one tweet which is
this tease of a photo accompanied by the
text four more episodes for the time
being thus implying that Togashi is
finally back and that the series will
continue for at least this many more
chapters but look I know what you're
thinking and what you're thinking is
that this probably isn't true because
that's exactly what I was thinking the
first time I saw that tweet I mean over
the past three years this fandom has
been subject to some very elaborate and
well not so elaborate hoaxes regarding
the return of hunt Hunter and each time
they capture us only to dash our hopes
again and I mean the concept of Togashi
being on Twitter Twitter of all places
did seem a little bit odd I mean the man
is a notorious recluse he very rarely
appears in public and has traditionally
stayed away from this whole online
phenomenon which I say because Hunter
Hunter did actually start before the
internet became this amazing and
terrifying place that's that's just how
old it is however this tweet was swiftly
followed by another from yusuke Morata
the illustrator of one punch man and
this tweet confirmed that this is indeed
the account of the real yoshihiro
tagashi so look unless this is a very
elaborate and may I say very cruel
trolling attempt I think we're back in
business which is ridiculously exciting
because even though tagashi is only
promised four chapters compared to the
zero of the last three years look I'ma
take it so new chapters that's great and
all but what does this actually mean for
Hunter Hunter and really who even
remembers where the story of Hunter
Hunter left off because I suspect the
vast majority of fans have completely
forgotten the exact plot points in play
it's really hard to say plot points in
play I've discussed of it plot points in
play plot points in
[ __ ] the Final Chapter we do have to
date is chapter 390 which is very
unfortunately titled Clash part one
which I suppose is interesting because
it means that togashi's exit from that
run was a very sudden Hiatus because he
probably wouldn't have called something
part 1 right before an anticipated
Hiatus and of course this was continuing
the story of the succession War where we
are currently following krapika as our
key protagonist in his role as a
bodyguard of one of the khakin princes
involved in this death game and of
course all of this is taking place
aboard a vessel known as the black whale
one which is currently sailing to the
Dark Continent it sort of not really
it's complicated it's stupidly
complicated and that's why I love it I
mean just briefly the cocking royalty
think they're going to the Dark
Continent but the V5 and the hunter
Association have this clever ruse that
they're doing where they're gonna drop
the karkin family off at this this like
fake Dark Continent called the new
continent before proceeding to the real
Dark Continent and weirdly enough
chapter 390 in and of itself isn't
anything particular really special it
introduces us to a couple of new members
of the underground mafia families aboard
the vessel because yeah that's the thing
as a whole Mafia subplot happening as
well with three families one of which is
broccoli and another one of which really
likes kissing people in fact it's
literally her nenability she kisses you
and you get powers but they're basically
on a mission to spark a conflict with a
rival Mafia Family learn information
about their leader and I suppose
initiate a series of events that leads
to the titular Clash which I do take the
time to point out because I think people
hear the return of Hunter Hunter and a
lot of them immediately jump to like ah
gone kilowatt hisoka my familiar things
this is this is going to be great but
maybe just maybe calm yourselves a bit
because there's every chance that these
chapters are just going to be filled
with like miscellaneous mafia members
and bodyguards and stuff like that like
I can see it now the first chapter of
Hunter Hunter's return and to a lot of
people it may legitimately be the most
disappointing thing in the world because
it's just continuing the story of these
miscellaneous characters for me I'm
hugely excited though the succession war
is such a good arc when you take the
time to read and understand what's
happening and these miscellaneous actors
they are very compelling now with that
said there's also every chance that
Togashi doesn't do a direct continuation
because remember we've been on Hiatus
for many many moons now and people
change over the course of years and
Togashi may have some very different
ideas about where the series is going
from here so he could even cut to a
completely different subplot kind of
like how the hisoka versus crawler
Fighters came out of nowhere really
whatever the case I want to know what
you think leave your comment in in the
comment place with things like Anna are
you excited for new Hunter Hunter what
are your predictions for new Hunter
Hunter are we gonna get more than four
chapters whatever you want to talk about
I honestly don't care what you have to
say I'm just excited to be talking about
Hunter Hunter again oh and in the case
that this is somehow fake then the hell
to pay will make the Dark Continent look
like a delightful Island Paradise